Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Friday Chit Chat. Hi there. I've been holding on to something for a little while, not that long, but as my BFF, it has been really hard for me not to tell you this, Angela. What? I wrote it down because I want to get it right. Okay.
Sam, Cassie, Angela. Go on. Yes. Even the smallest person can change the course of the future. Have you been watching The Mandalorian? Is this Andor? No. No. You're not talking about Baby Yoda?
Oh my gosh! I am so sad right now! I'm sorry, can I have it one more time in the same delivery? Even the smallest person can change the course of the future. Paddington. No. No. No. It's um... Paddington. No, no, no, it's um. Paddington 2? It's a movie. It's, it's a, it's.
About friendship and a quest. It's. And adventure. Did you watch The Hobbit? It's Lord of the Rings. It's Lord of the Rings. Yes. And he's talking about The Hobbit.
Yes. Yes. Because Frodo has to throw the ring. Yes. Into the fire. You throw the ring into the fire. You watched it? I watched it. Oh my God, that's amazing. Wait, when did you watch it? How, what did you think?
I love it. Yes. I love it. And lady, as this movie is unfolding, I know I said I watched the first seven minutes and the first seven minutes is like being in a classroom and it pushed all my buttons, but Sam told me that it was like the edge and Sam told me that it was about best friendship.
And... Yes. It is. It really, really is. And so I stuck with it and I watched it and I loved it so much. Oh, I could cry right now. This is incredible.
And lady, I see why you love this movie. Okay, I made notes. First of all, elaborate birthday party. The biggest birthday party in the Shire. That's right. Fireworks, lady. Do they know how to throw a birthday or what? The big dragon fireworks that goes on. Yes, yes.
Wax seal on an envelope. I know. I know. There's a wax seal. Also, the hobbits on their journey, they eat giant hunks of cheese. Yes. Just handfuls of cheese.
Yes, they bite right into it. They have second breakfast. Second breakfast. Yes. And there are so many Matrix and Game of Thrones crossovers in this movie. It's like, there's one casting office for all these people. It's the mother of casting.
I loved it. That's my share. Who is your favorite character? Oh, uh, maybe Sam. Yeah. Oh, yeah? Yup. He's the truest friend.
The true, when he jumps in the water, when Frodo's trying to row away. I know. Is that the movie where he gives Mr. Frodo the speech, or he's like, if you're not strong, I'll carry you? Oh, and he's crying? Yeah. I don't.
I don't think so. No. Is it maybe? I'm on two towers now, everybody. Oh. I couldn't stop. I am obsessed. Okay, so do you agree the orcs are scary? Lady, not only are they scary, they're big.
They're terrifying. It's very... This movie is very gruesome in a way I wasn't expecting, but like, here is the thing. This movie is basically like a quest, survivalist zombie film set in a fantasy world. That's it. Like it's, it is like all the things that I love. It's got some Terminator too. There's being chased by this thing that can't be stopped.
Yes. You know, I mean, yeah. Ugh. The only thing is, like, I have to remember all the names of things, but. Yes. There are a lot of names and terminology. That'll become easier over time.
Yeah. It's already become easier. They're very good at repeating it. Mm-hmm. How, I'm sorry, how, can I say, how old are you? 51. Today's the day. 51.
Welcome. This is the year. Welcome to the Shire. Welcome to the Shire, Jenna. Welcome to the gathering. I'm so excited. To the Brotherhood of the Ring. I can't believe you're here, Jenna. I really can't.
Also, you guys know that when Jack, our son, watched these movies, he took it on himself, and he was a young kid to learn Elfish. So, and he also asked for his birthday for a Legolas wig. And we had a little cubby by the front door where we would keep like volleyball and flip flops. And there was a wig tucked in there
that would be spilling out right as you walked through the front door. You keep your umbrellas, your bow and arrows, you keep them by the door. And a wig, yes. And I would come home many days from work, and he'd be in the front yard with his suction cup bow and arrow and his legless wig. I mean, just what a delightful ragtag group of fellas.
I know. On a quest. On a quest. On a quest. My friend, for his birthday, we got him a cameo from Sean Aston, who plays Sam. Yeah. And it was the most feel-good cameo. Oh.
Like, it inspired all of us, not just our friend, but he was like, you have friends in the world that believe in you. Happy birthday. Aw. That's so great. Elijah Wood did a video for Jack. you have friends in the world that believe in you. Happy birthday. That's so great. Elijah Wood did a video for Jack. I was working in Vancouver and he was on a show there and we were staying in the same furnished apartment building and we would all go out together and hang out. We went to a bar called The Crow and watched Game of Thrones together.
So cool. And he did a video for Jack wishing him happy birthday. When I met both of them dressed as Big Titty Gandalf at LA Comic Con four years ago, I came around the corner and it was their first time seeing me and Elijah Wood looked at me and he went, sure, Sean Astin stopped me and he goes, explain. And I gave it like 30 seconds, I was like, oh, it's a meme.
And he goes, great. And then it was fine in his brain. I remember those pictures of you, Sam. Well, that was my Friday chit chat share, guys. I've been waiting to talk about it. You guys know in New Zealand, they have recreated the Shire. Yes. You know, you can walk in New Zealand. You can walk the path that they walked.
It's like over a thousand miles or whatever. Whoa. You can hike the Lord of the Rings path. But like through snowy mountains? No, not through the snowy mountains and not through the dragons or anything like that. Okay. Safety first.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, but that'd be pretty cool. And I feel like I would fit right in in the Shire. You would. I wouldn't have to duck going through the door. I don't like I would fit right in in the Shire. You would. I wouldn't have to duck going through the door. I don't think I would. I'll do it with you. I'll go to walk through the Shire with you.
Can we please do an office ladies trip to New Zealand? Oh my gosh. To walk through the Shire? Yes. Yes. Yes. If we had a picture of the four of us, maybe with big walking sticks, standing in the Shire.
Sam in his costume, of course. Oh, yeah. That's right. You might have to cover the titties up, Sam. Yeah, I think so. Because they are fully out. All right. Does anybody else have a share?
Nothing that can compete with that. I can't compete with that. I just, well, okay. I have this observation about Josh. Okay, go. I have this observation about Josh. Shoot. What is it? So, you know, he hadn't had a new car in a very long time. We had the minivan with the kids for a long time.
It's the people mover, you know, great car. He finally got a new car. He got a Kia. He loves it so much. And he washes it by himself in the driveway. And he just washed it and then I guess all the trees and all the things along the driveway are now blooming and every day his car is covered in these little yellow pollen
things. Yeah, yeah it's that time of year for sure. And so do you know what he did? What? He went and he bought a floofy thing on a stick. What are those? Oh, like a duster. But like special for a car. Like a giant one? Like a giant one. Okay. And I took a picture of him.
He doesn't know I took it out the front window. Yes. Every day, you guys, he's going out there and he's floofing his car. I don't know what it's called. Probably doesn't sound good. But every day he's gotta go. You know what?
Good for him. I know. He knows what he likes. Does he wanna just get a car cover? Does he wanna cover the car? I think he likes the floofing. I don't, I mean the car cover seems like- It's part of the ritual.
Yeah, it's therapeutic. Let the man floof. I guess so. I guess I'm gonna let him floof. I mean, he seems a bit obsessive about it. Well, he's not like out there under like the full moon doing it, right? No, he's just doing it several times a day. And I'm like, it's going to get stuff on it, babe.
I know it's a new car. I know it's your new shiny thing. We don't have a garage, you know, so we park outside. Which is very common in LA. There are not a lot of garages in LA. The way our house was built, I should say, was built in 1936. And the way they did the garage was sort of in the back detached. And the driveway is so narrow because this house was built so long ago that you actually can't fit a modern-sized car.
I don't know what they fit down this driveway. Like, basically, an oversized lawnmower is what fits down it. So anyway, I was wondering. I was going to put it to the the group and Josh listens to the podcast. So he's gonna be like, what the heck, you sharing about my car? Well, I'm gonna say I love it. I think especially in today's age
where I think sometimes as consumers, we can just be like, I don't know, very, what do you call it? Just kind of like throw away culture, you know? I love when someone takes care of something and care with something. It reminds me of my dad. My dad would do that.
This is a very, yeah, it reminds me, yeah. I would say just keep a watch, keep an eye on it. Put a flag on it. When it gets to 10 times a day, that's too many. Okay, okay. I'll like start a count. Yeah, exactly. Angela, can you do an experiment for us?
Yeah. One day, can you go out and flip the car and see how he reacts? Like, oh, just take over? Yeah, interrupt his rhythm. Like, maybe I'm curious how he reacts. Maybe he'll love it. OK, I will.
That's a good question. He did just buy a very special little, it's like a trash bag and a holder that attaches to the back of the seat. And he's really adamant, if you have a granola bar wrap or anything, it's gotta go in that little caddy attached to the back of the seat.
You guys, he's loving this car. Well, you know what? Because he's ready to have an adult car again. Yes. He's ready to have an adult car again. Yes. He's ready to have a car that is like clean and doesn't have all the like little kid crepo in it. And every time you get in it and turn it on and turn it off, the dashboard lights up and it goes, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing,
bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, b Anyway, you guys, that's my Friday chit chat. My husband is real happy with his new car. I have a second Friday chit chat,
which is that I've been fostering some kittens through kitten rescue. Oh yeah. And I need them to be adopted. Four, you have four kittens. Four kittens. So we have four kittens, an adult cat and a dog. And so we have six animals.
There's only four people in the house. It's getting crazy. And speaking of like zombies, these kittens, it's a little bit like living in a zombie movie where like they'll be sleeping, but then if you come upstairs and you like creak the floor, all their little heads pop up, and then they all like slowly start walking towards you.
But then they also are like both four separate things and also one organism. So it's like they can do things, they can cover such a wide area with their mayhem and then they all come back together and then they split apart and then they all come back together. It's like the fungus in The Last of Us. Yes, exactly. Anyway, please go to kittenrescue.org and fill out an adoption form. Please adopt these kittens if you live in Los Angeles. Please adopt them. They're the modern family litter.
Their names are Manny, Claire, Haley, and Chinny D, aka Phil, aka Chin Dot. He's got a dot on his chin. We started calling him Chin Dot and then that he's now Chinny D. And they're all great. They're all A plus kittens. Please adopt them. Please adopt them. And also, I think one of the things that tickled me the most about today, we've been in the studio for a while, is that when Sam said, oh, like the fungus on the last of us, Cassie went, oh, what is that? I'm just thinking of these little kittens, you know, being little zombies, I love them.
All right, guys, have a good Friday. Have a good Friday. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.